puis très heureuse d'apprendre que vous
étiez en guyane la semaine dernière je
pense que vous avez pris le pouls de ce
qui se passe au niveau des pêcheurs
guyanais est parce qu ils sont en grande
souffrance et je pense que et je compte
beaucoup sur vous pour pouvoir les
accompagner et puis les aider un pour
s'en sortir parce que je peux vous dire
que nous les parlementaires nous sommes
très souvent interpellé pour les
accompagner trouver des solutions mais
c'est un peu compliqué même si nous
avons auditionné madame la ministre de
la mer qui nous a apporté des réponses
mais qui j'avoue ne nous conviennent pas
forcément en tout cas qui sont loin de
la réalité alors j'aimerais vous poser
deux questions 3 quels sont les freins
au développement de la filière aquacole
en outre-mer et comment y remédier
vous avez répondu à la deuxième
et puis quel peut être l'avenir du
secteur de la croisière en outre-mer il
ya un enjeu d'investissement et de
continuité dans l'investissement et il
faut il croire qu'il ya une part action
psychologique depuis une part de 2 400
psychologique qui a une part de l'ontt
et politique il ya une part de gros sous
le secteur de la croisière je l'évoqué
est est ce que oui ou non on investit
est ce qu'on est bienveillant à l'égard
de l'accueil avant la crise politique et
sociale actuelle
l'attitude de l'état sur le refus
d'accueil des bateaux de croisière y
compris de petite taille en fin d'année
aux antilles c'était tout de même pas
une réponse ce n'est pas une réponse
indispensable mais le sanitaire et si la
réponse économiquement qui était tout à
fait fâcheuses
sur le développement de la filière
aquacole où on l'a évoqué il ya des
enjeux de deux formations moi je ne
permettrai d'insister sur ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure qui est la
continuité de l'action publique je pense
que le stop and go qu'on a connue en
guyane est absolument catastrophique
s'il s'agit d'encourager aux métiers de
la mer alors nous explique par ailleurs
je prends l'exemple de la guyane j'étais
la semaine dernière des guyanais ne sont
pas tournés vers la mer je pense que
l'argument ne suffit pas que ce soit en
guyane ou sur d'autres territoires si la
politique de l'état est trop
discontinues c'est compliqué d'organiser
des formations et c'est compliqué de
convaincre les jeunes de s'y engager
j'ajoute que la question de la formation
est une responsabilité partagée entre
les collectivités locales et l'état si
tu poses évidemment une discussion
suffisamment
riche et féconde entre l'état et que
l'intimité nature le prix du fret a
considérablement augmenté que ce soit en
outre-mer ce soit en métropole
simplement évidemment dans des économies
insulaires ou
assimilés insulaires comme la guyane
l'importance du fret dans la composition
des prix est beaucoup plus considérable
qu'elle ne l'est en métropole à ces
questions de prix du fret il faut
ajouter des enjeux de disponibilité et
en préparant cette audition je lisais
combien la disponibilité est à la fois
lié à l'organisation de l'offre mais
aussi tout simplement c'est intéressant
d'avoir en tête des enjeux de
fabrication de conteneurs contraint par
la pénurie à certains moments d'acier et
d'aluminium